on this episode I talk about
micromanaging versus delegating and
monitoring my employees behavior on
social
[Music]
you ask
in
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 176 of the askgaryvee
show we're back on our home turf I feel
like that rented Stadium over there
changed up our vibe it's been
interesting the saltiness the weirdness
IP by the way I let me start with this
and let's get a show and actually we
were shooting the [ __ ] but wait I've
gotten dick pics already by the way it's
super shocking no I have one and
whatever like you know what you know
what's funny it's not shocking as a
whole like if I looked it up I wouldn't
be shocked it's just that you don't
expect like yes you don't know what's
coming I think we used up all our time
so I told them we'll do one question but
I'm already feeling it so maybe we'll do
a couple more go a little faster but up
for everybody watches or listen to this
in to speed this is about the field
maybe for speed can I just say thank you
to everybody like for a second the
amount of you in these and dailyvee and
then the couple of salty episodes the
last two days the amount of you like
Gary I see something terrible is going
on in your life through your eyes or
like Gary don't worry I know the
pressure and the were like well and not
that not the same old characters that
are always bantering with me like a lot
of people have emailed me DM me or snap
me in the last 48 hours checking in on
me which is so I'm so thankful it makes
me happy too because it also you know
what I my mom has said this to me for a
long time she calls me sunshine and she
says that because she says that I
elevate everybody's mood like when
around me it's and it was really
interesting I really felt it from the
community that because I wasn't at my
100 like yeah like people felt it or
like wait a minute
hey Gary this is what I signed up for
like people really like hi man I know
your spiel this point I signed up for 20
minutes because I want to get jazzed and
feel good I'm like damn it is it like
like it's really fast and I push against
this I don't want to be positivity and
motivation and energy I also want to be
tactical and operational and put myself
out of business if you haven't read that
article you know and so thank you
because that is
super flattering and I do think selfish
to a couple of you so I will bring your
levels up right now India so India let's
get into so no no stick with me do this
do this for me ready yes the Shah great
thank you Brock Lesnar okay
okay Brock amazing go ahead so it's
gonna show up as a snap screen Oh like
that got it awesome uh you talked about
the importance of willing one-to-one
relationships through your social media
and by the way let's do that guys one of
the things that is uh not scalable right
now or I haven't found the app yet and
I'm busy I want to throw more snap
obviously I'm all-in on snapchat don't
know if you heard um you can download
your video from your story uh and
probably from your one-on-one
interaction I just haven't done that so
I don't know can you like if you send
somebody a message in video form can you
download that to your phone alright
maybe you can or if you actually you
know what
even better this will get you know what
actually don't get I'm going in for you
know what I'm changing I'm flipping the
switch here I'm going in for a right
hook
I already people were emailing me that a
lot of value has been provided to them
on the snapchat strategy and good things
have happened I want you to do the
following I want to do a series of shows
like this but this is my right hook I
want you to add the askgaryvee show
and garyvee GA ry Vee
sandal follow him on snapchat in your
like ask me a question for the show in
your snapchat story and then tell people
to follow me at Gary Vee on snapchat
because I appreciate it I want to build
up my father I'm going in for a ride
hook but then download that because you
put on your story so all your people are
gonna see it but then download it and
submit those questions
you know there's put on your Twitter or
I don't want to do email so put it
somewhere where we can see it so I think
email or or Instagram right they can
download it that's what I do I take
direct thoughts right I know it's like I
know you're always worried about like
who cares if it looks that way you do um
anyway so so let's get some snapchat
questions on that way
I would probably tweet at India that
you're doing it at you know this way I
don't want to double game it and get
your Twitter exposure to I don't want to
eat it like the story is more than
enough at India let's put up India's
handle here for the few that don't know
and embed your question on Twitter from
snapchat and let's get a bunch of
snapchat questions and video form it's
your chance to get your face in front of
tens and tens and tens of thousands of
people hundreds yep
Brock Lesnar Brock says you talk about
the importance of building once one
relationships through your social media
and that you should do the same for your
customers and employees
do you follow many of your employees and
like comment on their personal content
traditional management would say know
what say ye I follow ya what really
managing through social yeah I mean I
engage I'm always I'm always laughing
when employees like we're closer we get
to spend more time but there's obviously
employees as you can imagine that maybe
I don't even get the scene for four
months and then I'll show up in our
Instagram and say yeah and so I can
picture of like her and her boyfriend
she's and she's like this is the
creepiest [ __ ] of all time
you know like look I'm not following any
company rules because I'm not scared of
being sued because I truly believe in my
life that intent trumps everything like
you can sue on anything you know like
anything at any time about old like you
can make up anything and so so the
answer is how did he ended the it like
how the IC said what it was that no no
the end what do you say how does the say
or what is it ye says that that I watch
a lot of the content everyone's putting
on it remember I made a reference like
oh India's putting up like okay but it's
like I put up like a nice picture uh-huh
yeah but like something like you like
Leigh Leigh anyway you know like
nonetheless like I'm seeing what
everybody's doing and there's a lot to
see there's funny stuff but don't forget
it's public domain right like it you
know on Instagram they have to accept me
if they want to follow me like I don't
feel like I'm intruding because it's the
rules of the game
I'm watch
I'm watching because I want to know them
better to bring them more my intent is
to follow so I can make it better for
them not so Oh Stefan you're fired you
drink beer too late at night intent
intent is what trumps everything and
then I engaged because I'm coming from a
good place and they get pumped like a
lot of employees are happy when I engage
because I think it's cool and like
they're like lookout weird my bosses you
know like you know what I mean like so I
just think intention so yes I follow yes
I engage I don't engage a lot because I
do have respect for like like everybody
views these things definitely so I'm
trying to be smart I don't wanna make
anybody uncomfortable but my intent is
pure as you know like I wanted to be
good I'm doing it for good and so I'm
not scared
like executives and companies are bad
often they don't care about the
employees so their intent is bad hey we
need to cut 50 people from payroll this
year you let's follow people on social
and blame them for like that's what
happens guys what do you think's going
on that's what's going on that not
everywhere but that's what intent you
can do anything you want like you know
companies that are highly regulated
pharma financial they're scared of the
government suing them so they're not mad
at the cut employees they're just doing
governance so that they don't become
exposed as a company so I understand why
they have that I don't put intent if you
are a financial service and you're
monitoring your people and you're not
letting them be on social media because
the government makes you feel that
you'll be fined for doing something
that's not intent that's bad
they'll just protect that got it like
don't look at the tactics trail it back
to the intent right so Jerry V
vaynermedia is awesome they can do
anything okay but your police might not
be not awesome it might be more
vulnerable to things maybe your CEO is
also scared of those kind of things that
isn't like maybe if I got massively
burnt one day in my career I take a step
back and change intent always changing
Steven Steven asks Gary are you more of
a delegator or
micromanager can't wait for the UK book
tour uh both I delegate everything that
I think is not the single most important
things in the world and then I
micromanage the things that I think are
the most important things in the world
luckily for me hence why I've been able
to build big companies I don't think
most things matter so I don't think I'm
any different than anybody else
I actually think everybody is a
delegator and a micromanager I just
think that my radar of what's important
is different yes we need to do something
with that that's the [ __ ] guys that's it
right there
I'm look just like you we're all the
same we all delegate we all micromanage
the difference is I don't think most
things matter and what do I mean by that
as I'm trying to think about somebody
watching this for the first time instead
of alluding to like people that have
watched forever most things don't matter
like it's like I don't know like just
bladder that's what it means like you
know like if I was like I don't know I
don't think lighting matters as much as
d-roc like I just don't think things
matter like I don't think like one
client that's gonna put us out of it
like I don't think one employee's gonna
kill our atmosphere like like like I I
don't think a lot of things matter I
don't think like crud like a misspelling
in a deck is something that really
matters to a lot of people in my company
it just doesn't matter to me I just
don't think so guys guys I don't think
we're gonna lose a count because we put
the I before the e and if we do them
idiots
I don't think not being I don't think
not wearing shoes in an establishment is
you know the biggest thing in the world
clearly if you've watched daily be one
some people do and guess what I do not
judge do not judge everybody's allowed
to do their thing it's just like
parenting I will never speak my
parenting I talk about it but it's very
holistic like this is what I do not what
I'm telling you to do this is me but
good like so ultimately I think that I'm
both like everybody in the world I just
think that I deem what's most important
at a very very high level on things that
most people you know what a lot of you
were commenting about my five-minute
meetings most of you
a part of my community you think it's
great a lot of comments in YouTube and
Facebook I'm like oh I like daily
because Gary spends five that's nice
I've one comment I work in a small and
by was whoever said this is going to see
this and be like holy crap he reads
everything I work it I've worked at
small companies where the boss didn't
even know my name you know what I mean
like this is cool but you know many
people think it's stupid I have a lot of
people in my life that think that I'm
very busy and I have a lot of things to
do and why in the world Gary it's not
scalable it's not sustainable yeah
you're making that face because you're
so in our cocoon but like boy just like
like you know like they're like don't do
that it's not bad nobody expects you to
do it not at this scale and you have a
great culture and you have great intent
just do that I'm like nope this thing
matters to me so micromanaging a hello
into my company three to six months in
that a lot of people outsource to an HR
person or the leadership so I do
unscalable things all the time
micromanaging if I deem them the most
important pitching new business I like
to micromanage that because it's
important to win business like money
helps me keep doing everything I really
should go this I'm being a jerk oh
really yeah question of the day what is
the thing that you most micromanage
because you believe it's the most
important thing that you're doing in
your world today love you guys
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]